hi I'm Erik Bosse and after watching
ant-man in the wasa the most important
takeaway was the quantum realm something
this sequel spent a lot more time in
than the first ant-man did so what new
things we learn about it and how could
it set up events for Avengers for now we
have started to discuss these questions
and other videos on this channel but
here let's really dig into it what is
the quantum realm what is its backstory
from the Marvel Comics what does it tell
us about what we're gonna see an
Avengers for and of course spoiler
warning if you have not seen ant-man in
the wasp yet okay so the quantum realm
refers to the dimension that exists on a
subatomic level accessed by shrinking
down endlessly between atoms to access
this inner space as opposed to outer
space Scott Lang won in the quantum
realm and ant-man and was stranded there
in the post-credits scene in this recent
sequel a sequel that showed Hank Pym
going down to the quantum room to rescue
his wife Janet Van Dyne and we get to
see this whole trippy colorful design
world of the quantum realm it seems like
it could be its own weird little
universe the movie's director Peyton
Reed hinted that he did hide little
visual clues in the background of the
quantum realms imagery kind of like he
did with the shadow of the wasp that he
hit in the first movie in my breakdown I
did find this image which looks kind of
like some kind of city or civilization
what could this place be other than a
smudge on the lens well it does help to
look back at the Marvel Comics the
quantum realm is just a cinematic
version of the Microverse also known as
micro world or sub-atomic a-- it's an
entire dimension of subatomic star
systems planets and civilizations it
shows up first in the Fantastic Four
comics dr. doom uses a shrinking ray
against the Fantastic Four but they
later turn it against him and dr. doom
has seen the shrinking endlessly until
he disappears that settles that but
later the Fantastic Four began shrinking
randomly so with the help of Hank Pym
they shrink down to investigate
realizing that dr. doom didn't disappear
he just shrunk down into the Microverse
and he's been spending all this time
living in the star system of subatomic
a' conquering a world called mir wood so
during this time in a Microverse we also
meet the lizard men of the planet talk
or talk before the Fantastic Four gets
saved by ant-man and a Doctor Doom
please lead in the comics there's a
character cycle man from subatomic ax he
gets involved when the Silver Surfer
hides from Galactus in the Micra
and there's a later Marvel Microverse
story when Scott Lang shrinks down into
microworld to look for the thing and he
finds him living it up down there as a
gladiator fighter the storylines
actually very similar to thor ragnarok
within this whole Microverse there's
also a place called homeworld which is
kind of a molecular chain planet that
was conquered by this figure named Baron
kartha it's inhabitants possess a world
mind it's kind of a shared sentience
that can be controlled by one leader and
tapped as an energy source
so really the microworld just contains a
lot of different colorful characters and
races of civilizations and locations
that are just established in the Marvel
Comics that the MCU could draw upon to
adapt into the quantum realm in the
movies so this thing that we saw in
ant-man the wasp if it's a city perhaps
it could be an MCU version of mere wood
or Tok Tok or homeworld and maybe this
places inhabitants could be characters
like The Lizard Men or Baron cars Oh or
cycle band or something completely new
entirely really it's too soon to say
whether the quantum realm is how the MCU
plans to introduce a fantastic for
Doctor Doom Silver Surfer you know since
Disney will soon acquire Fox's Marvel
properties and yeah it's probably too
soon to determine if Janet Van Dyne is
lying about evolution could be a clue
pointing out the x-men which is another
Fox Marvel property that will eventually
join the Disney Marvel Studios family
but you know very watching ant-man the
wasp and hearing all this frequent
techno jargon about quantum physics and
quantum everything it suggests to me
that the future the MCU may go even
deeper into science and theoretical
physics one area study examines the
connection between inner space the space
between atoms and outer space the space
between stars and galaxies but there is
that assuming that the universe spawned
from the Big Bang the explosion of one
particle that the laws that govern
gravity and motion and the vast reaches
of the universe must be the same as the
laws on the tiniest scale within matter
my point is is that maybe we shouldn't
see the quantum realm as like a dead end
just some expanse where you can just get
lost in perhaps we should see it as a
kind of tunnel that leads to something
else
remember the quantum realm did show up
briefly as one of the many dimensions
Doctor Strange floated through so if
it's among the mystic powers of the
sorcerer supreme to traverse through
this place it could be more of a bridge
than a bottomless pit
so I think it's possible that Scott Lang
doesn't need to be rescued from the
quantum realm maybe he just needs to go
deeper into it to see what's on the
other side perhaps we'll find an
einstein-rosen bridge which is something
that we have seen before in the MCU
remember The Devil's anus I'm Thor
Ragnarok and every time the Bifrost has
been opened up it's a wormhole that
leads to some other realm and space so
if Scott emerges out of the other side
of a wormhole with some kind of quantum
healing energy that he's gathering in
that post-credits scene I could see that
being very useful for Tony Stark and the
rest of the surviving Avengers in their
final fight with Thanos there's also the
theory that the quantum realm could
cause a phase shift into a parallel
reality remember earlier in ant-man the
wasp dr. bill foster Laurence
Fishburne's character lectures to his
class about quantum physics and he drops
this key line of dialogue about how
phase shifting like the kind experienced
by ghosts could on a quantum level
caused a split in two quote multiple
parallel realities so if Scott gets a
similar affliction during his time with
quantum realm perhaps that could cause
him to slip into an alternate parallel
reality perhaps an alternate timeline
where the other half of all I've
survived an Iron Man captor and the
others faded away
we could see some kind of twist in
Avengers 4 where Scott merges these two
realities collapsing them onto each
other bringing the two halves of
existence back together in other videos
I've looked at those leaks set photos
showing the devices on all the Avengers
hands and I point out that they kind of
look like Pym particles this could all
be related I'm just saying you've got to
take a cooper Morpheus here and free
your mind to see the various options of
how the Avengers could use the rules of
what's already been established in the
past the MCU to fix what Thanos broke
but just a question I want to pose to
you do you think the quantum realm is
more likely to lead Scott to a separate
parallel reality or lead to a portal
back into our surface reality or is it
really a bottomless pit comment with
your thoughts down below or tweet me
directly I da vas and follow the new
rock stars on Twitter for updates under
videos like this video share it around
and subscribe to new rockstars for
similar in-depth theories about the
Marvel Cinematic Universe to expand your
imagination and make your head hurt
thanks for watching bye